- Welcome everyone.
I'm Saad Omer and my title
for the next six weeks is the
Director of the Yale
Institute for Global Health.
And I'm also a professor both
in the schools of medicine
and public health here at Yale.
As most of you would know,
I am delighted to welcome
you to our last conversation
series event for this academic year.
As you know, this is
the Conversation series,
global Health Conversation
Series is run by the Yale
Institute for Global Health,
but this event is in
collaboration with the Yale
School of Public Health.
Specifically with the
epidemiology of Microbial
Diseases seminar series as well.
The overall,
the conversation series is all
co-sponsored by the McMillan
Center and their Walker fund.
As we have learned through the
COVID 19 pandemic that health
transcends boundaries.
You know,
something that emerges in
China, shows up in Washington,
and then within a week and
a half in Connecticut and,
and in many parts of the
country and the world.
We have also learned that by,
by promoting healthy behaviors,
investing in healthcare
infrastructure and specifically with
a focus on equity helps everyone,
both domestically and internationally,
especially if these lessons are shared.
And the beauty of this country
is cooperative federalism
kind of infrastructure, is
that we have at least 50 labs.
Unfortunately, not all those
lab experiments go well, but,
but the idea is that we
learn from each other,
especially if things are
implemented in good faith with the
best possible interpretation of evidence,
but also evaluated and shared
so that's the beauty of
treating the local health as
part of a global whole
that we all benefit from.
So in today's event,
we will discuss these important
issues and how global health
is essentially sort of derives
a lot of its strength from
for what happens locally.
And for our discussion,
it is my immense pleasure to,
to welcome two distinguished
experts and leaders
joining us today.
So the first one is Dr. Manisha Juthani.
She's one of our own,
she's on public service leave
from the School of Medicine
and where she's a professor of medicine,
her day job these days is
the commissioner of the
Connecticut Department of Public Health,
a department which was actually
owes a lot of its existence
and founding to Dr. Winslow,
who after whom this auditorium is named.
And so this institution has a,
a long history of contributing
to the state's public health
infrastructure and,
and she's the first Indian
American to serve as a
commissioner in the state of Connecticut.
So again,
is a leader in from that aspect
as well as we emerge from
the pandemic.
She obviously helped
lead the covid response,
but she continues to focus and,
and that comes into
relief a little bit more,
efforts to deal with the
other public health issues,
including the tragic opioid
crisis, lead abatement,
gun violence,
and especially evidence-based
approaches to addressing it,
mental health, climate and health.
So that's an existential
threat we have that transcends
boundaries, has global
and local implications.
Maternal health and,
and drinking water infrastructure
improvements are some of
the other areas that she's focusing on.
She's committed to growing the
public health workforce and
which y'all are part of the public health,
emerging public health workforce.
And someone told me there are
40% vacancies are open in the
department of public health.
Is that a?
- Little bit less than that,
but yeah, we're hiring.
- So exactly, that's the point.
And especially those of you
who are sort of, you know,
formatting your CVs for May and
the ones who are graduating,
one of the best things to do
right after an MPH program is
to work for a good well run
state health department,
and especially if you don't
have to break your lease.
And so, you know, that's a,
that's a pitch of staying
engaged, et cetera,
and including those who want to have a,
a subsequent research career
as well and research or a
career in medicine.
So this is,
so not just those who wants to, you know,
work in a health department
for the long term as well.
My other guest is Dr. Umair Shah.
He's the Secretary of Health
for the State of Washington.
And he made that trip from Texas.
So his training was at Vanderbilt and,
and a few other places and then was the,
the health commissioner for
Harris County around Houston and
led the response both in
emergencies and non-emergency sort
of healthcare functions for
that important populous and
diverse county in the US and
was there when, you know,
around Katrina and,
and some other major disasters
around Ebola and Zika and
sort of all sorts of
things that came his way.
It was almost like a sandbox
video game where, you know,
things were, you know,
thrown in his direction.
and he, you know,
came out of that stronger and
with several lessons that he
took with him to the state of Washington,
but beyond as well.
He's very active in the
National Academies of medicine.
So over his career he has been
a clinician and innovator,
an educator and a leader in health.
He has been particularly
a champion of underserved
communities, but with a
focus of substantive action,
not just sort of talking
about it, which is important,
but we're taking action.
and he's,
his career has always been at
the intersection of health and
healthcare while charting a,
a fresh course in health by
centering cornerstone values of
equity, innovation and engagement.
So we are honored to have you
both here and I'll start us
off with a few questions for,
for the two of you and
then we'll open it up
to the audience.
So the first question
is actually both of you
and both of you are, you know, to,
to use a military term war tested,
combat tested generals in public health.
What is the immediate course
of action to be taken locally
when a global health event occurs?
So maybe Dr. Shah, I can
start with you and then
with Dr. Juthani.
- Well first of all, thank you Dr. Omer
for having us as part of
this convening and thank you
interim Dean Pedigrew and,
and the entire school of
public health and just really
appreciative of the
opportunity to be here.
So, you know,
I think this is really
the defining question.
As we are coming out of a pandemic,
we see the question for the
future about when something
happens globally, how do we act locally?
And I think this really
underscores the intersection of
global and domestic health that
we no longer can be thinking
about watching something on
the news cycle and recognizing
that it's over there 'cause
there is no over there,
over there is here.
And very quickly something
that can happen in Hartford or
New Haven can spread all the
way across the globe and flip
it around the bidirectionality
of the fact that it can
happen elsewhere.
And now we are dealing with it here.
I always saw with Covid
19 initially when, and,
and obviously, you know, as Dr. Omer said,
I was in Houston, I was in Texas,
but the state of Washington had
the first case, as you know,
in the continental United
States of Covid 19.
We had the first case,
we had the first
unfortunately first outbreak,
and we also had the first death.
These are milestones,
they were unfortunate and sad milestones,
but they were also important
for the rest of the nation
because what was happening in
Washington, people like us,
whether it was Connecticut or in Texas,
were watching it play out and
what was happening in one part
of the nation or one part of
the globe as we were learning
of what was happening
in obviously in China.
But we were also seeing it
spreading through Iran and
spreading through Europe and
spreading all the way across to
other nation states were
important lessons for all of us.
And so I'm very used to, in
Houston, hurricane lines,
you all the spaghetti
lines you see, you know,
there's a storm that's about
to hit and you see all these
lines and I remember very
early in the pandemic thinking
about where is the actual
spaghetti line for Covid 19.
The first thing that all of us
in public health were trying
to do was to figure out where do we get,
where are we going to have
our first case in our local
jurisdiction?
And that was, it was,
it was really a disease
detective case of trying to find
that first case.
And ultimately you had the
spaghetti lines of hurricanes and
storms that were pointing to
where was gonna happen across
the country and it just
happened to be just north of
Seattle.
So I think the key question,
the real response is that we
cannot sit and rest on our
laurels when something is
happening elsewhere because
ultimately it will impact us locally.
- Thank you for the introduction.
So great to be here with
you Umair and all the Yale
community that I've been
a part of for a long time.
You know, one, I wanna make one
other plug for the students,
which is there is also a
Connecticut Department of Public
Health fellowship that
people can apply for,
for your summer experiences.
I see a few people who maybe
know what I'm talking about,
but again, this is what gives
you experiential learning.
You get paid too,
to then be able to enter
the public health workforce.
So to the point and question
about what is global
and now local,
I wanna just highlight even
more when we say local in the
state of Connecticut,
we think of the state as
local if you're first thinking
about that. But in the
state of of Connecticut,
we have 61 health
departments and districts.
The city of New Haven
has a health department.
We as a state need to work
with our local partners because
that's who's actually on the
ground in the community dealing
with the health crisis as it's emerging.
And so we really have to take
local to the really local
level and it's really on us
as the state health department
to be able to work well.
It's been one of my priorities
to be able to work well with
local health to be able to
execute on these concepts.
And what I would say is that
as we've heard, what is global?
Global is local.
As an ID physician,
we were sitting here at Yale
New Haven Hospital waiting to
see where that first case was
gonna emerge in the state of
Connecticut as we saw things
coming and then to New York and
moving up that I 95 corridor
and where it was gonna happen.
So I saw it from the perspective
of a practitioner and
director of the Yale
ID fellowship program.
And you know, now are,
am at the state level and the
number one thing that I can
say is preparedness.
It's those preparedness plans,
it's going through the exercise
and recognizing that any
threat can emerge at any time
and you need to be prepared
for whatever that might be.
You have to have plans in place,
they may need to adapt and
change depending on the
circumstances,
but without a plan it is
very hard to execute on that.
And we've learned so
much from the pandemic,
which we have put into place
in terms of our plans and
preparedness as a state.
But without that,
you're already behind the eight
ball when something emerges.
- So both of you lead
sort of the health efforts
in diverse states.
Connecticut is a little bit more compact.
Washington has both just not
just diversity in terms of its
population, but also
worldviews and geography.
So from, you know, Spokane,
et cetera in the east to
Fairy County, which is,
it was tea party before there
was a tea party to Vashon
Washington, which is the
peak of crunchy granola,
former hippie, current formerly hippie,
currently rich crowd.
And yeah,
- Great place to visit by the way.
- Yeah, wonderful place.
The whole state is
wonderful and Yakima County,
which is partially
populated, but you know,
reasonably pro-public health.
So with that diversity,
how do you engage the community because
it's not one community.
How do you work with community leaders?
Is there a model to do that,
especially when you can't be
the health commissioners for
just the conservatives or just
the liberals while being in a
democratic society where, you know,
appointees are political?
- Yeah, so first of all, I,
I would be remiss if I did
not join my colleague here to
remind everybody that
we have great internship
opportunities as well.
Great volunteer opportunities.
We're a great place to work,
we're an incredible state.
So please come to the state of Washington.
I just wanna let people know
in this room and beyond,
you know, please come and we
are absolutely willing to,
to recruit and we're not
shameless in the process.
I just wanted to make that quick plug.
What I would say a a couple of things.
So, you know,
I came from a deeply different,
maybe that's the better
way to to say it, context,
right?
The state of Texas is on
the political spectrum,
more conservative.
It's what we refer to in the
popular vernacular of a red,
red state than you go to
Washington and you've got
a blue state.
So you got red and blue.
What I find, and you know, Dr. Omer
you and I have talked about this,
is that you get that diversity everywhere.
I'm sure you get that right here.
Five minutes from this campus,
you may get it right here in this room.
Think about that.
We assume that everybody has a
certain political perspective
or persuasion, that is so inaccurate.
And so when I came to Washington,
my first comment at my,
one of my press briefings was to say,
I am the state health secretary,
not just for one side of Washington,
which everybody knows
is the I five corridor.
Everybody thinks of Seattle
and just north and just south,
where the majority of our
population is in the state of
Washington.
But I am the state health
secretary for the entire state of
Washington.
And then that played out in the
midst of our vaccination and
our covid response efforts that no matter,
and our tagline was,
no matter who you are,
what you look like, where you
live or what you believe in,
you should have access to
and fill in the blanks.
And that is what health does.
It levels and evens out when
there are elected officials and
policy makers who are having
the partisan discussions.
We must rise above that no matter what.
We have to be connecting
across the aisle because our
communities are on both
sides of that aisle.
And shame on us in public
health if we're unwilling
to do that.
And that's where the diversity,
not just of the community comes in,
but the diversity of us as
practitioners comes in as well.
- So you are right that there
is intellectual diversity in
this room.
There are indeed 15 shades of woke here.
And I'm just joking.
There is true.
I have found true
intellectual dis you know,
our students here,
I'm very proud of the
fact that the discussions
have been substantive.
There have been multiple
ways of looking at the world,
et cetera.
And so you're absolutely right
in that coming to the more
operational issues.
So when you are doing a response,
but also more broadly, so,
so the job of a health
commissioner or secretary of health
is not just strategic, not just visionary,
but also operational.
So how do you maintain
that logistical resilience,
both for the emergency
response but also the,
the other things people are
going to need sort of screenings
and referrals and all
sorts of other stuff.
So how do you operationally manage that?
So maybe Dr. Juthani.
- So I came into the job as commissioner
in the middle of the pandemic.
And within a few months
of being in the job,
omicron took off.
So I came into the job
when we were running fast
and had to figure out the
job and figure out how to do
emergency response while at
the same time not completely
dropping the ball on all the
other routine public health
types of things that we need to do.
And we see the consequences,
quite frankly in our society
of the fact that it was
difficult to manage social
distancing and children being
outta school.
And we see that impacts
of that on mental health,
on gun violence, on so many other aspects.
Maternal mortality,
congenital syphilis rates in Connecticut.
We had eight cases of congenital
syphilis in the last year
when we had years of none, zero.
That is because of a lack
of access and accessing of
maternal health services for many women.
And that's a travesty.
We know how to deal with that.
That's just regular old public
health doing what it does,
what medical care when it's
running in its usual way in our
state really is.
So I think for me,
we were sort of flying the
plane and building it as it was
going, you know, for example,
self-test kits were just coming
out and we were trying to
buy them and respond to
the omicron wave as it
was all happening.
And so, you know,
now everybody's got more kits
than they know what to do
with, you know, and, but
that was different back then.
Now we're trying to continue
to rebuild and maintain that
infrastructure on so many of
the general public health basic
principles that we need to have in place.
And it's a different tempo in some ways,
but every day day there's a new emergency,
quite frankly that comes up.
It's this different in scale.
There may be a smaller group
of people that are affected by
that given emergency.
It's not maybe the entire state.
And I think that I,
I just wanna make one comment
about even though we are a
blue state boy, do we have
diversity in this state?
We have rural areas of this state.
We have all the same
disparate voices that you see
in a red state.
And we have the same challenges
even though we are generally
viewed as a pro-public health
type of state where people
often think people are
of the same mindset.
That is not the case.
And you do have to have an open
mind and recognize health as
a human right and being able
to provide that to everybody
and not just those who are
the same mindset as you are.
- So when you arrived
from Texas to Washington
in terms of you arrived when
the vaccine became available
sort of right around the time.
- That same week.
- The same week, yeah.
- My wife was not happy
with that decision.
- And then sort of Washington
has done fairly well
in terms of equitable
distribution of vaccines,
in terms of objective metrics, et cetera.
Obviously it took some
effort and all of that.
What are some of the approaches that,
specific approaches that you
applied to make that happen?
- Well that's, you know, it's a long,
it's a short question, long answer.
I'll try to keep it very brief.
There were a number of things
that we did and I did arrive
the week of vaccines in the state.
Fortunately,
I arrived in a department that
was supported by a governor.
I have to be very, very clear.
Governor Insley was a champion
for health and continues to
be, many people know him in
environmental health and climate
climate change and the
impact on climate, on health.
But that translated and transferred
over to his reading and,
and studying and,
and commenting and being
all in when it came
to Covid 19 response.
And so, yes, the first case,
first outbreak, first death.
And yet you fast forward two
years later and or two plus
years later and we still have
the six lowest per capita
death rate in the nation.
And that's quite amazing when
you think about all that.
So the specific strategies, Dr. Omer
were really very much that
it was all in for Washington,
that we had to do everything we could.
We did the work with our
local health jurisdictions.
We have 29 officially recognized tribes.
So we worked with our tribal leaders,
we worked with our faith leaders.
We were in communities.
We actually for the first
time had a state asset called
Caravan where we deployed
state units that went into
communities that communities,
700 of them asked us to come
in and help with vaccinations.
We had collaboratives for equity,
so we had community voice.
We also had a public-private partnership.
So in the midst of this is
really hard for government,
government oftentimes stays
on the public sector side,
right?
So we had our Starbucks, right?
We had Amazon, we had
Costco, we had Microsoft,
we had Gates Foundation, we had Google,
I mean just Alaska Air.
We had all of these,
these folks who were saying,
what can we do to help?
We brought them together.
So when Starbucks said to us,
the governor asked us, there's
a specific example we need,
I wanna make sure you're gonna
stand up for mass vaccination
sites in the next 48 hours.
And we did it, okay.
But we stood them up and we
reached out to our private
sector partner who were
part of our collaborative.
And Starbucks said,
if we can get a latte in the
hands of consumers 35% more
effectively and efficiently,
we guarantee you we can make
your mass fact site faster and
more efficient.
And guess what they were right.
But shame on us in public
sector for unwilling
to take that offer.
That's the kind of all in
Washington approach that we took
to unturn overturn every
stone to be able to respond.
And that's how we were successful.
- I think that's a really
good example of that
as long as Starbucks is
not putting down names
of people on cups or vaccines.
So I've been called Sad
- Not gonna comment on that one.
- Exactly, SOB or SAD et cetera.
Sometimes that reflects
the state of mind after
I look at that.
But other than that, no,
it's leveraging sort of,
it's truly all hands on deck approach.
So both of you are not
only public health leaders,
but are employers of
folks that come out of
the public health educational system,
a lot of them from the
schools of public health and
medicine, et cetera, and nursing.
What do you think,
if you had the choice of
redesigning the skillset that
people come out with from these
programs that is relevant to
not just a health department
for applied public health,
what would be your
advice if you were given
that opportunity?
So maybe we can start with Dr. Juthani
and if you might wanna
add something there and,
and that's something for
everyone, both faculty and others.
Like, we need to be connected.
We need to be responsive to
the needs of health departments
and the broader local
and state public health.
- So I think there's
different types of roles
in local health departments
at the state level.
So for example,
epidemiologists that deal with data,
you maybe get very good training
at learning how to analyze
data, how to gather data
and be able to present it.
I think some of the other
skills that are really useful in
health departments relate
to project management,
being able to provide deliverables,
be able to present data more publicly,
learning how to interface
with policy makers and
legislators.
And I know there are different
tracks in public health
schools and some public health
schools are a little bit more
research focused.
Some public health schools are
a little bit more hands-on in
terms of getting those skills
to be able to do jobs in
public health and some schools
are sort of a mix of the two.
And I think all public health
schools are trying to train
people to do all of the above.
But I think being able to get
some concrete skills in public
speaking and presentation,
analysis of data and being able
to communicate the value of the data
that you are identifying
project management to be able
to say you've been given a
task and be able to see it
through and be able to actually
deal with the nitty gritty on
a lot of these things are some
very technical skills.
I think some of the other
things that we see in our local
health departments, for example,
we in our in Connecticut local
health departments do a lot
of the environmental health safety.
So whether this is on septic
systems or sewer systems,
whether you're doing
food protection safety,
which is another huge thing,
you need scientific training,
you need to have done science
classes to actually be able to
understand why does temperature
regulation of our food.
Like if you,
we oversee restaurants and wanna
make sure that what they're
serving is safe and that
you don't get salmonella or
something else when you go
to eat in a given restaurant.
Well why is that?
And that scientific training be able,
is able to help prepare you for that.
So there's really such a breadth
of types of jobs that are
available in public health and
getting skill sets in those
various areas are the things
that I would encourage people
to think about and think
about what the end goal is,
even if it's a first
job right out of school.
And what kinds of skills
you might need to be able to
prepare yourself best and
getting some of that experiential
internship training to be able
to prepare you for that type
of job at the end.
- And I'm gonna have Tony
give me a copy of our
transformational plan.
Thank you Tony,
my wonderful assistant who came
from Houston to Washington.
So really thank you Tony for joining.
So we recently launched our
transformational plan and,
in the fall of this last year.
And I'm so excited about
this transformational plan.
It's built on our three
cornerstone values of equity,
innovation engagement, has five areas of,
of reflection and one of the
areas where the first state
health agency in the nation
have global and one health as
one of those five.
But another aspect which
is really exciting,
in fact just this week we
launched the recruitment for the
leader of that area at our
department the first time ever
that we're going to have a
leader who's going to be lead
leading global and one health
together in our agency.
Our second area is health
systems and workforce
transformation.
And I just want to add
to what Dr. Juthani said,
and by the way, whenever she
speaks, I always learn so much.
There's wisdom that comes,
comes from being around her.
And what I would say is the
number one thing that we have,
the number one challenge that
we have in our field right now
is our workforce hands
down our workforce is,
is challenged.
It is tired, it's ragged,
it's been beaten up, it's
been vilified, it's been,
it's been attacked, it's been demonized,
it's been caricature by
a excuse my French here,
bastardization of public health.
So all the things that Dr.
Juthani just mentioned,
when you go into the popular media,
when you go into a whole host
of people asking about what
public health is and or if
you're gonna try to explain it to
to your neighbor,
they are not going to understand
restaurant inspections or
those other things.
They're gonna see the popular
media of what the caricature
of our field is.
And what that means is that
people have left our field,
people have left our field and
people are going to continue
to leave our field.
In fact,
the De Beaumont Foundation is
saying that our field is going
to see an exodus, a third of our workers,
our field is going to see in
the next five years more people
leaving and a third have already left.
Think about that.
So when we talk about
the skills that we need,
it has to be people like
you in this room and beyond
thinking about how do we
contribute to the future
of public health.
We know it's critical,
but we've gotta have that as part of it.
The second piece is that there's
so many skill sets that are
not always taught in the
theoretical classroom of public
health schools or academia.
We have to have real world
experience that Dr. Juthani
just mentioned.
You have to know,
you have to volunteer, you
have to be a part of it,
especially in emergencies,
but also in blue sky days.
You have to be a part of that
to understand the skillsets.
And then the final thing is this real,
a lot of the incorporation
embracing of other ways of
looking at the world, whether
it's debate and dialogue,
how do we do that respectfully
but also forcefully and
assertively.
We should be willing to be
able to take our field and
respond in kind and a
solidarity for our field.
But the second piece of
that is those skill sets and
communications and engagement
and policymaking and as I
mentioned, debate and dialogue.
These are skill sets that
are oftentimes not taught in
schools of public health
in the same way that
they should be.
In fact, they're not even
taught in medical school in
the way that they should be.
And so we have to do a
better job with that.
- Expand on it a little bit.
Dr. Shah said that, you know,
these are tough times for public health.
So there are two kinds of
people who run away from,
from the fire and firefighters.
You have to decide are
you going to run towards,
are you a firefighter?
Is that your calling?
And I think that should be,
that's the ethos of our
profession in public health
and medicine.
And there's nothing more
gratifying than to respond and the
privilege to have the skills
to be able to respond.
So take that as a challenge.
You're coming out of programs
in public health, medicine and
nursing and others and take that,
take up that mantle and help
redefine public health because
I can tell you on the
other side there's a lot of
gratification.
It's tough, but you will be better.
You know, your patience
will be tested, but,
but there is gratification.
So I, we have, you know,
people in this room who were
at the beginning of the HIV
epidemic and there are some
of the best role models that
many of us have now.
And I'm sure there did not
know how it'll end when there
were in the thick of it
in Brooklyn or, you know,
other parts of New York or other places.
But, you know, history will
remember them really well.
So with that, I will open up
this, you know, forum for,
for some questions from the audience.
I have plenty of questions of my own,
but would love to hear something from you.
There are microphones there,
so if you could raise your
hands, I saw your hand first,
so we'll go there first
and then we'll come here.
Number two.
And introduce yourself and
then you can ask your question.
- [Natalia] Hi, thank you
so much for your talk.
I'm Natalia I'm MPH first year student.
So I wanna flip coin a little bit.
You've talked about what you
do at your local and state
level departments and it
seems that even though the US
healthcare system is such a
strong and there's so much
budget and there's so
much going on, it still,
it was very hard for the pandemic.
So how are you sharing in
any way this knowledge and
preparedness to the global field?
So how is this local knowledge
translating into other
countries or other similar even
states in the US, thank you.
- I thought, thank you for that question.
I thought you were going
in a different direction.
So maybe let me try to answer
where I thought you were about
to go and then I'll,
I'll try to answer your
your question specifically.
I thought you were actually
going into the healthcare system
and the challenge within
healthcare and public health.
And so the underinvestment
in public health is a real
challenge that we have a real concern.
So for decades we've underinvested
in public health and then
we have a a pandemic and
why are our data systems not
robust enough?
Why is the workforce, you know,
not able to do X, Y or Z?
Why is it that we don't have
the right systems in place?
Why do we not have health
agencies that are robust enough to
be able to respond?
Well it's because we've underinvested.
These are policy choices that
we've made when 96 cents on
every dollar in the US in health
is spent in healthcare and
we've all three of us as physicians,
we have responded in
the medical community.
We know what that means and
we have incredible amount of
respect for our medical community,
but we know it's necessary
but not sufficient.
And that's where public health comes in.
So now let that's where I
thought you were going but
so that was, here's the question.
So in our global and
domestic health work and the
envisioning that we're doing,
it's very much about the bidirectionality.
So oftentimes in the US we
have this hubers, right?
We're going to take our ideas
and we're gonna send them out
to the world because we have
so much to teach the world when
in actuality it's
bidirectional that we have
so much to teach.
Yes, but we also have so much to learn,
especially in resource constrained
environments that by the
way they feel very much
like everyday USA in many
communities that are also
resource constrained.
So one of the tenets of our
global work is to actually learn
from other nations and to then
contribute back with those
same opportunities in kind so
we can change the landscape of
learning across the system.
And then Dr. Juthani
I know you and I are both with
the association of state and
territorial health officials
and we share across other
states within the US so maybe
you can talk about that.
- Yeah, thanks Dr. Shah, I was
just actually gonna say that,
that one of the reasons we know
each other and I learned so
much from him regularly as
well as because of the national
organization called the Association
of State and Territorial
health officials where we meet every week,
sometimes more than once
a week and really have the
opportunity to learn from each
other and leverage what one
state is learning over
another one and being able to
operationalize that.
And I think that that camaraderie
and group is a very unique
group 'cause there's 50
of us and then you know,
the territories who participate.
But I totally echo your points
on how we need to learn so
much from what's happened
globally as well.
I think not having, you know,
one health system really
in our country has made it
difficult in many ways.
So many things of the covid
response were done in many ways
better in other countries.
So I think we have a lot to learn,
although we have a lot to
also share with others.
- And if I may plug your new
office or maybe you can sort of
highlight that because I think
it's very relevant to this
question because it's,
I think the first time state
health department is taking
that initiative for having
a office of global health.
- That's right.
- State health department.
- We're actually calling
it OGO 'cause we try to be
a little bit,
you know, kind of swanky different,
the Office of Global One,
which I think is really cool
and it's an opportunity for us
to really be thinking about just that.
And so it's,
we're actively, as I mentioned,
we're recruiting this
week, we just launched,
we're so excited about this,
the recruitment for that leader,
the real opportunity ultimately
is to take multidisciplinary
and interdisciplinary areas,
global domestic health,
one health, right?
Human health, animals, the environment.
I always say entomology as well, insects.
So we don't forget mosquitoes
and always everybody
forgets mosquito.
I don't know why everybody
forgets mosquitoes.
Nobody in this room
forgets mosquitoes, right?
Okay, but a lot of people do
the intersection of all that
because that's truly what
health is about.
And then you throw in and,
and remember the impact of
climate and the changing
environment and so climate and health.
And so it makes so much sense.
And by the way,
there's an incredible
resonance, Dr. Omer with tribes
when you think about one health because
when our tribal leaders,
they speak about one of
many of the issues that are
happening in on their lands.
They're very concerned about
what's happening with the
intersection of humans,
animals, and the environment.
So we're very excited about this.
We think it's a path forward.
So back to Dr. Juthani,
the comment is as we are
launching these things,
we want to be able to share
with other states and other
localities across the country
and that relationship.
And remember we're very close to Canada.
We're right next to Canada.
And so we have a binational
relationship with what's
happening in Vancouver, what's happening
in the northwest right
across the border as well.
- And this is very much the
ethos of the Yale Institute for
Global Health.
We don't define global health
in the context of geography.
We, our find core value is health equity,
that all lives are created
equal and population's economic
status doesn't have to
dictate their health destiny.
And so therefore when you look
at it from that perspective,
it's not about here and there.
It's not colonial or post colonial,
it's an orientation.
It's about the shared humanity
and the shared journey that
we all have.
And that when you start
with that position,
you arrive at these kinds of
things where you say that all
of us have to learn for example,
a community healthcare
worker program is a,
a very essential public health
innovation that for once has
some resources behind it and
we need to get that right.
But one way we will get this
right is by learning from our,
you know,
partners around the world
who have done this reasonably
well, not everywhere,
but in more than enough places
that they're sort of valuable
lessons there.
I'll come to you for the question.
- And as you're going to the next question
I would just want to
add with, when we were vetting
our transformational plan,
we realized that there was
obviously resonance of what was
happening in some of the larger areas,
but when we went to some of
our rural areas, they said,
you know, immigrant
populations and populations,
agricultural farm workers or,
or other aspects or what's
happening with our folks who are
going overseas or back there
is resonance there as well with
global and domestic health.
- [Larry] Thank you.
I'm Larry Vilano from
the Child study Center,
psychology and psychiatry
next door at the School of
Medicine professor there.
So I wanted to ask you
all what your thoughts
are about this.
We all are under pressure to
kind of respond to the loudest
voices, you know,
the loudest student in our
class or the loudest patient.
And so we all know that if
we do that we miss out on the
quiet voices.
And how do you,
how do you think about that
and how do you defend against,
you know,
being worried about the loud
voices who have a lot of power,
or at least they think they do and,
and the quiet voices who feel
they don't have the power,
you know,
how do you do that and how
do you decide where to put
the resources and efforts
and you know, not miss out?
Thank you.
- So I think some people are
very good at advocating for
themselves and their issues.
Some groups are good at doing
that and sometimes they're
good at doing that for the quiet.
And I think the strength
as a population is in
community organizing and
creating a synergy of people who
can advocate for a given voice
and a given topic so that
your loud voice does become louder.
Now that doesn't answer your question on,
so what do you do as
somebody who's sitting
on the other side?
I guess I raised that because
I do think what I see from
where I am now is that it is
true that the people who are
able to organize and are able
to get their message out and
are able to come together, do
get their voice heard more.
But there are many groups that
have been successful at doing
that for often voices that are not heard.
So that's a credit to those
people and those community
members who've found a way.
Let's take gun violence as an example.
You know, we have groups
right here in New Haven,
right in Hartford that have organized,
that have put themselves together,
that are representing the grassroots,
whether you talk about HIV care, you know,
there's so many different
topics where you can get
people who have shown that
they've been able to make their
voice more heard, I say on,
on the side of somebody
who's in state government.
Now I think when we try
to address these topics
that we recognize,
'cause our job is really to
recognize what are the public
health problems that are
really affecting our state.
And when we do that,
to have an open mind on
who should be at the table,
who should be reflecting their points,
and to be open in the way
that we bring those people
to the table.
And I think that I see that
happening in state government,
but I also would say that
people who get the ear of their
state legislature, their legislator,
so for anybody who has an issue, you know,
talking to people who have
that seat at the table already
helps advance that point.
A lot of people don't
feel empowered to do that.
Every single one of us has
the right to contact a state
representative, a state senator and vote.
Quite frankly,
these are the ways that
we can exercise our agency
on these things.
But I do think it's on us to,
and what I try to do is bring
all those voices to the table
anytime you're trying to
address those big problems.
- I would just add intentionality.
We have to really be intentional
in the process and Dr. Omer
is an expert in this.
I mean, this is an area where,
you know,
he has spent a lot of time
with both researching but also
advocating and articulating this publicly.
And what I would say is that
one thing that will remind
ourselves is that we do hear
from the extremes on both,
both ends and the vast
majority of Americans,
the vast majority of Americans,
I believe are in the middle.
They're truly in the middle.
They're worried about
their kids going to school,
they're worried about food on the table,
they're worried about how their job,
they're worried about the
stress of everyday life,
they're worried about tomorrow.
That's the vast majority.
And yet the loudest voices get the,
the airplay and that sucks
the oxygen out of the room.
And what the biggest challenge
for us is to be intentional.
So we can also speak to both
sides as well as understand,
recognize what's happening in the middle.
- So although not intentional,
but we find ourselves as
at this last conversation,
global health conversation series,
event of the academic year with
an all minority panel and in
fact for the first time
an all South Asian panel.
And so I think it will be,
I'll take this over too.
- Woohoo.
- Exactly.
And you won't find any
of us calling that thing
Chai tea latte.
It's chai.
And so.
- Does everybody even understand,
you might wanna explain that
one a little bit more, yeah.
- So milk tea is chai, there's
no latte, there's no milk,
you know, milk tea,
it's chai and that's a
hill I'm willing to die on.
(audience laughing)
So coming back to that, so
coming back to the sort of,
to the main point that
of course, you know,
leadership is often about sort
of being the first in a room
that hasn't seen someone who
looks like you or who has
the same gender or sexual
orientation or the,
the rural background or first
gen or the underrepresented
minority or the immigrant background.
And of course there are
fewer glass ceilings,
but there are ceilings
made of jello still there that
they put up resistance and so
therefore they're often more
nuanced and harder to navigate.
So both of you are trailblazers
from that aspects as well.
And to put you on the spot a little bit,
we get to do that in the academia.
That's why God created tenure.
I'll start.
- For you, but not for us.
- So maybe you can start Dr. Shah
and then Dr. Juthani will end it with your
thoughts on this.
Something that, you know,
lessons from being trailblazers.
- You know,
I think the lesson that I
take away is that yes, we're,
we're South Asian from
a background standpoint,
but it's more than that.
That is where we come from.
That's maybe our value
helped instill values.
It's where our families,
our ways of learning,
you know, how our parents
raised us, our culture,
our food so much in
incredible rich heritage.
But ultimately when you're in
the work world and when you're
in the professional world,
it's about competence.
And we wanna make sure
that the people are good
at what they do.
And that is the ultimate number one thing.
But we also recognize to
the earlier question about
intentionality, when
we are also looking to,
to our workforce or to the
next generation of leaders,
like all of you,
we have to be intentional in
making sure that we're also
broad in our perspective and approach.
So we also look like,
and start to mirror the very
communities that we serve.
And that has not always
happened in this country.
And that's why it's gotta
be an equity-based approach.
And truly that is where leaders
like us can bring that trail
blazing, if that's what it's called.
I really believe it's really
the way we should operate and
do our work.
- So I think many people
saw many South Asians at the
forefront of the covid pandemic
on TV in your hospitals,
everywhere.
And you know, the,
I see us as standing on
the shoulders of giants,
our parents and others who
came before us that helped
get us here.
And I think in terms of being, you know,
the first or in these roles,
these new roles that
are more public facing,
I view that as an honor, privilege,
and obligation to be competent
and to do the job well and to
showcase for others that if
I can do it, you can do it.
That all of you who are
in the room, you know,
you are students now you
are inspired by COVID,
You were here because you wanted
to be a firefighter because
you wanted to be at the
forefront of addressing
these concerns.
And so I see that as our
challenge and goal is to inspire
and show others that you too
can do that you too can join
this fight as we try to advocate
for what's most important
in health in our society
and in our country.
- Thank you.
Really appreciate it and it's
a privilege to have you as
guests for this conversation series.
And thank you for coming.
As you know that this is a
new era for public health.
You all have to do, you know,
especially the students and
early stage faculty have to do
better than than us, you know, than,
than the current cohort because
there's no other choice.
Because the next generation
of challenges at the state,
local and global levels are existential.
So the impact of global climate change,
the fact that we have had a
shrinkage in life expectancy in
the richest country in the world.
The fact that this city's map
of covid mortality looked like
where brown and black people lived,
that should be unacceptable.
But we have the privilege of
having the tools and being at
institutions and having
access to the knowledge and
understanding to gear up for that,
that struggle, that fight, if you will.
So no pressure.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
(light ambient music)